- Du jamais-vu au Brésil ou
dans son palais de l'Alvorada,
dans la capitale Brasilia, q
refuse de dire quoique ce soit
au vainqueur Luiz Inacio Lula
indice de ce qu'il compte faire
réréré la pression de ses
ministres et ses conseillers.
deux petites minutes dans
lesquelles il ne reconnait pas
le résultat. Mais une petite"J"r
à tous les commandements
Or après une élection en bonne
et due forme que personne
ne conteste, la constitution
la passation des pouvoirs
le 1er janvier. Il en attribue
la tâche à son chef de cabinet.
"Le président m'a autorisé à l ,
le processus de transition."
Mais Jair Bolsonudududududududue
le système électoral en disant
que les manifestations actuelles
traduisent bien le fait qu'il
doivent pas troubler l'ordre
public ajoute-t-il.
Donc, il n'appuie lelele blocage
des routes du Brésil déclenché
depuis le résultat de l'électio)
Presque tous les États sont
touchés. En particulier celui
de Sao Paulo : artères
conges
international de Guarulhos
paralysé, des centaines de vols
annulés. Les routes pour
le Brésil sont le seul moyen
et des denrées périssables.
camionneurs qui bloquent les
routesf f f peut-être la police
fédérale de la route elle-même,
qui compte beaucoup de partisans
visiblement laissé faire.
Les tribunononont confirmé
que les blocus étaient illégaux,
les participants seront frappés
les polices ont été mobiliséesp.
Avec très courte allocution,
la crise constitutionnelle'y'y's
de contestation de l'élection.
Celle des camionneurs devrait
l'être aussi si la police
parvient àmamamamamamamamamamam,
c'est la fête des morts.
Les Brésiliens devraient
se sentir soulagés.
Radio-Canada, Rio de Janeir